what is Hydroponics hydroponic gardening
is a method of growing plants without
soil in hydroponic gardening the water
does the work in this case the work of
delivering nutrients to the plant roots
in order to grow plants Hydroponics is
the cultivation of plants using water
nutrients and a growing medium it's
growing without using soil there are
different types of hydroponic systems
there's the wicking system as its name
States a WI and a phenomenon called
capillary action the nutrient solution
will slowly but regularly and constantly
spread from where there is more to where
there is less water as the plants need
it you may also see an ebb and flow or
what is called flood and drain system
the basic concept of an Evan flow
hydroponic system is fairly simple
plants are placed in a tray which is
periodically filled with nutrient-rich
water pumped out of a reservoir below
the system uses gravity to return the
water to the reservoir to be reused nft
nutrient film technique nutrient film
technique is a hydroponic technique
where a shallow stream of water
containing all the dissolved nutrients
required for the plant growth is
recirculated past the bare roots of the
plant in a watertight Gully also known
as channels aeroponics are specialized
versions of Hydroponics where the roots
of the plant extend only in air and the
roots are directly sprayed with a
nutrient water in a drip system of
Hydroponics the water-based nutrient
solution is delivered to the root system
of plants using drip irrigation drip
systems are ideal for vertical
hydroponic farming since the nutrient
can be placed at the top and gravity
sends it down to the rest of the plants
dwc or deep water culture is one based
on a tank called a grow tank where you
have the nutrient solution and an air
pump to provide air to the roots there
are a few disadvantages to hydroponic
systems the initial costs are sometimes
higher a deeper knowledge is needed and
sometimes they need a little bit more
attention having thought about the
disadvantages I knew the proven
advantages were worth an initial
investment in a small hydroponic system
what are the benefits of hydroponic
systems plants grow
significantly faster when existing soil
is poor Hydroponics is the best option
Hydroponics crops yield from 20 to 25%
greater than soil it requires less space
and uses a lot less water than soil
farming Hydroponics also has a lot of
health benefits eating more vegetables
can improve your overall health no
pesticides are ever used in Hydroponics
growing without soil reduces and
minimizes the risk of contamination from
growing vegetables in dirt that uses
manure
and the vegetables harvested from our
hydroponic system last 2 to three times
longer and can be harvested even after
being cut two to three times dwc or deep
water culture fit our family's needs and
it was a great place to start
Hydroponics is too simple and too good
for me not to share it with you after
you set up your Hydroponics for food
system you'll have a continuous supp
supply of delicious and nutritious salad
greens herbs and vegetable
[Music]
plants